oggi abbiamo sentito parlare di cose
incredibili
un mondo veramente interessante
un mondo in cui le macchine parlano con
le case le case parlano con le strade
noi ci colleghiamo con sette oggetti
attaccate al nostro corpo che parlano
con altri 100 mila persone un mondo
veramente interessante
e mentre ascoltavo i relatori prima di
me è sempre bellissima vedere quante
cose ci sono da imparare
mi domandavo a tutte queste cose
meravigliose
ma chi le ha inventate
questo mondo in cui viviamo queste case
che abitiamo queste strade su cui
camminiamo le regole che osserviamo i
parametri che ci diamo ce li ha dati
e allora mi sono fatta una piccola
ricerca per oggi sono da vedere un po di
invenzioni che adesso vi faccio vedere
ok e il 16 luglio del 1945
la domanda è questa quella che vi
opposto nokia caschetto questa
meravigliosa drammatica favolosa
imperfetta storia che stiamo vivendo il
16 luglio del 1945 siamo ufficialmente
entrati nell'antro picene
l'antropocene l'era geologica che segue
loro ce ne è
definita da questa cosa di vita dalla
data in cui è scoppiata la prima bomba
atomica nel new mexico e questi 24
indicatori ci dicono che in questa epoca
iniziata nel 1945 l'attività umana e il
sistema economico globale sono diventati
il primo driver del cambiamento del
sistema terra quindi siamo ufficialmente
nell'epoca in cui l'uomo
definisce l'andamento della terra ok ma
le parole sono sempre molto interessanti
la parola antropocene viene come sempre
da da una parola di origine greca che
vuol dire essere umano altro post la
parola altro passo non vuol dire solo
essere umano vuol dire anche
uomo
esiste una parola greca anche per la
parola donna
che però non ha niente a che vedere con
antropocene ed è di un e
quanta parte ha avuto la donna nel mondo
che viviamo oggi ha avuto un ruolo c'è
stata andate a vedere le invenzioni
fatte dalle donne vennero riportate
alcune mi devo dire che un ruolo c'è
stato
io ho lasciato per ultima la mia
preferita in che ovviamente conosce
anche davide perché questa signora
dell'intelligenza superba è riuscita a
cambiare il metodo di allevamento dei
bovini e in particolare riuscita a
renderlo meno doloroso per gli animali è
interessante perché questo ha migliorato
anche l'efficienza però il suo primo
intento era abbassare il livello di pena
per gli animali che una cosa tipicamente
femminile
noi seguiamo altri parametri e oggi
ancora oggi le donne hanno una
partecipazione molto marginale al nostro
mondo vi do solo dato nella classifica
mondiale dei paesi per la sorte per la
partecipazione socio economica delle
donne l'italia si piazza al 100 14esimo
posto su 142 paesi questo vuol dire che
in italia che è ancora credo l'ottava
potenza mondiale le donne non
partecipano alla società e all'economia
non partecipano siamo cento 14esimi su
142 paesi
non abbiamo il velo non siamo chiusi in
casa ma non stiamo partecipando però sta
succedendo qualcosa di nuovo e la cosa
nuova riguarda una cosa che piace
moltissimo gli uomini un numero un
numero 1 miliardo di donne un miliardo
di donne stanno entrando nel mondo del
lavoro nei prossimi dieci anni entrerà
un miliardo di donne con un impatto sul
mondo del lavoro più alto di quello di
cina e india messi insieme ci sono
alcune di queste donne anche in questa
stanza
guardatevi intorno e potrete vedere
e allora la domanda che potrebbe
apparire anche gli occhi preoccupati dei
colleghi che mi hanno preceduta è ma che
cosa succederà che cosa succederà con
l'ingresso di un miliardo di donne nel
mondo del lavoro perché entrare nel
mondo del lavoro vuol dire diventare
cittadine vuol dire partecipare vuol
dire avere una voce avere un'influenza
lavorare vuol dire questo
ecco noi non possiamo sapere esattamente
che cosa succederà non abbiamo tutte le
certezze che abbiamo sulla tecnologia
sui prossimi numeri le cose che crescono
propria una matta che ci consente di
provare alcuni indicatori interessanti
su quello che potrebbe succedere questa
mappa loro cervello che oggi grazie alle
nuove tecnologie possiamo osservare
molto bene il cervello che noi abbiamo
un cervello che comunque si è costruito
almeno nei 200 mila anni di storia della
nostra razza della nostra specie homo
sapiens esiste a 200.000 anni il
cervello così come oggi buona parte
delle nostre reazioni dei nostri istinti
vengono da questa storia di 200.000 anni
il nostro cervello ci dice una cosa ci
dice che maschi e femmine sono due
specie diverse sono due specie diverse a
livello cerebrale e a livello di una
serie di reazione e questo perché lo
possiamo scoprire ma per non da vedere
questa nostra storia questa nostra
tradizione nella sua parte
quantitativamente più rilevante cioè
tutta l'epoca in cui noi abbiamo vissuto
nelle caverne che è stata molto lunga
rispetto a quella che viviamo oggi
allora cosa succedeva voi avete un'idea
più o meno di quali fossero i ruoli
per esempio nel maschio tradizionalmente
ma ancora oggi la produzione di
ossitocina che è un ormone con cui il
nostro cervello ci premia cervello premi
ai nostri comportamenti rilasciando si
cucina che ci fa stare bene veniva
generata dalle attività di lotta ancora
oggi nel maschio nel padre per esempio
lo sito cina viene generata quando gioca
con i figli perché la natura ha deciso
che il padre debba giocare con i figli
nella femmina lo sito cina ancora oggi
viene stimolata dalle attività di cura
noi proviamo benessere quando ci
occupiamo di qualcuno quando curiamo
quando coccoliamo
proprio perché il suo compito primario
era cacciare il maschio ad ora il
movimento a dura tutto ciò che si muove
adora il calcio la formula 1
ad ora tutte le cose che si muovono ma
non è un caso il nostro cervello sia
abituato ad amare il movimento la
femmina non correva che tra gli animali
la femmina se ne stava lì si segnava fai
questo fai quello il nostro cervello ci
premia e ad ora l'organizzazione il
controllo su tante cose mettere a posto
tutto a pato noi troviamo le cose negli
ambienti piccoli non le troviamo negli
ambienti grandi non troviamo l'animale
nella savana ma troviamo il calzino nel
cassetto
viceversa
adesso sapete perché
il maschio è tutto su vinci o perdi
l'animale o lo catturi o lo perdi
nell'attacco vinci o perdi non c'è
alternativa cervello si è formato così
questo era essenziale per la
sopravvivenza per la femmina non c'era
vinci o perdi c'era una creazione di
alleanze per la femmina era importante
la comunità
ha così mio preferito
il maschio si focalizza uno va bene
motivo prima che permette la bestia non
devi acchiappare la bestia inseguita
bestie vedi la bestia colpisci la fa il
sasso kakos focus focus di nuovo la
versione di sopravvivenza è cioè almeno
allora era questo adesso non lo so cosa
serve però c'è anche adesso questa
cervello è fatto così guardate questa
immagine questa è una scansione
elettromagnetica di due cervelli maschio
e femmina dopo vi faccio indovinare
quale maschio e femmina a riposo sono
illuminate le aree attive a riposo
come vedete c'è un'area che ha tante
aree illuminate uno dei due cervelli e
quello femminile le femmine attivano più
aree contemporaneamente sono più
abituate a fare connessioni tra le cose
a collegarle i maschi sono molto più
focalizzati quindi è più facile che
siano geniali nel vecchio senso del
termine perché vanno più a fondo sulle
cose si sanno concentrare meglio
e infine il mio preferito il compito
primario del nostro cervello la ragione
per cui si è voluto così come si è
evoluto è l'abbassamento dello stress
ricordiamoci che nella preistoria lo
stress era un segnale del pericolo il
pericolo era un pericolo di morte
quindi il nostro cervello si è abituato
che quando sente stress fa qualunque
cosa la cosa più efficiente quel momento
per abbassare lo stress si dice e noi
sappiamo e cultura comune che di solito
di fronte a una situazione di pericolo
l'uomo attacca o scappa la conoscevate
questo modo di dire attacca scappa
ragion per cui anche sul lavoro si
suppone che tu attacchi o scappi è un
parametro di successo
un parametro condiviso di reazione in
situazioni di tensione
adesso vi domando
ma una femmina
che sta colo su piccolo in una caverna
secondo voi di pronta una tigre di
quelle col con i denti a sciabola
attaccherebbe
scapperebbe lasciando indietro i bambini
l'istinto più profondo della donna le
dice che se scorrerà del sangue e quella
caverna in quella piazzola sarà con ogni
probabilità il suo o quello dei suoi
figli l'istinto primario della donna è
non scappare ma proteggere e creare
alleanze perché la donna è debole e si
occupa della prole e il nostro istinto
più primordiale
la metafora della battaglia che è quella
che noi ancora oggi vediamo ovunque sui
giornali quando si parla di politica
quando si parla di potere che parole
leggete vince perde attacca la corsa al
colle i nemici la metafora della
battaglia o addirittura ci siamo evoluti
siamo passati alla metafora sportiva
quindi si dice appunto
gara in barca a vela come insegnare
insegnamento di management e così via
ha però con sé dei legarci molto
importanti ha con sé dei limiti nella
metafora stessa in cui noi stiamo
vivendo come se fossero dati
noi stiamo disegnando il mondo dentro
quei limiti che sono i limiti che ci
sono dati da queste da queste due
metafore e quali sono questi questi
limiti uno me lo voglio leggere perché
l'ho scritto io mappe non lo so mai dire
bene
uno è che in questo modo di definire la
parola potere e questo modo di definire
il risultato è l'orizzonte temporale
limite ci schiaccia perché l'adrenalina
vive di momenti e non ci consente di
guardare più lontano del momento stesso
della battaglia noi dobbiamo vincere
subito
noi dobbiamo avere stato subito quanto 6
milone danni risultato vinci o perdi e
vinto e perso adesso
vittoria dopo vittoria gara dopo gara si
succedono piccole battaglie dagli
orizzonti temporali che sono asfittici
a nessuno interessa quello che verrà
dopo e il potere di napoleone qualcuno
l'ha citato prima napoleone ancora così
ammirato nei salotti di chi dice o pensa
dopo di me il diluvio
qual è l'orizzonte temporale
il secondo grande limite che non ci
consente più care signore di stare fuori
perché queste parole vanno cambiate e il
concetto della gara il concetto della
gara implica che ci sia sempre qualcuno
che vince è sempre qualcuno che perde e
se invece noi provassimo a cambiare un
pochino questa visione se smettessimo di
pensare che sono tutte gare si allunga
assimo l'orizzonte temporale fino a un
punto in cui non ce ne importa più
niente di chi vince non ce ne importa
più niente a noi interessa il futuro ci
interessa andare in lontane non ci
interessa arrivare primi è possibile
questo pensare questo che non è più così
importante chi arriva primo
se ci fosse l'intento comune di
costruire un futuro
insieme
la voglia il bisogno di uscirne vivi di
uscirne bene
alle donne per come siamo stati fatti
per il compito che ci è stato dato
interessa la vita
la cura ci interessa il dopo ci
interessa quello che lasciamo i nostri
figli
vogliamo che i nostri figli ci
sopravvivano o no
e la domanda successiva che dovrebbero
farmi gli uomini a questo punto in
questa sala indignati anche un po
arrabbiati
e ma tutto questo interessa anche a noi
un po
abbiamo imparato quasi tutto quello che
sappiamo dagli uomini
tutto quello che abbiamo ci hanno dato
gli uomini e forse è venuto il momento
che noi donne ci prendiamo la
responsabilità di insegnare la nostra
volta qualcosa di dare la nostra volta
qualcosa
come abbiamo visto forse tutto questo
non interessa solo noi e io sono molto
convinta che insieme possiamo cambiare
il mondo grazie